Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Jagir Bayram.
Ich bin als Assistenz-Hearts auf die Station tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Annahmen-Netzige führen.
Sind Sie da mitteinverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Kurzem Ablauf.
Als Erstes würde ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Daten stellen,
dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Jan Neuberger.
Herr Neuberger, können Sie Ihre Vornahme bestabieren?
Jan.
J. Anton Nordpol.
Nachname Neuberger.
Nordpol Emil Ulrich Bertha Emil Richard.
Gustav Emil Richard.
Ja, danke.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Neuberger?
Ich bin 22 Jahre alt.
22.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 9. März 2000 bin ich geboren.
2000.
2000, wie den jungen Kind.
Ja.
Groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß und 80 kg schwer.
78?
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 kg.
Okay.
Herr Neuberger.
Entschuldigung.
Was stürzt ihr zu uns?
Ich bin heute Fahrradgefahren.
Beim Fahrradbahn bin ich ausgerutscht und gestürzt.
Seitdem tut mir mein rechter Schulterbereich weh.
Rechter Schulter.
Rechter Schulterbereich.
Das tut mir weh.
Wenn ich meine Schulter bewege, habe ich Schmerzen.
Okay.
Sind Sie auf Ihrem Schulter oder auf Ihrem Hand?
Ich bin direkt auf meine Schulter gefallen.
Okay.
Sind Sie auf der Außenseite meiner Schulter?
Ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie Ihren Kopf auch etwas gegen etwas gestoßen?
Sind Sie mit meinem Kopf nicht.
Ich hatte einen Fahrradherrn.
Ich bin hier im Schulter gestoßen, aber ich habe auch einen Fahrradherrn gehabt.
Ich habe mich am Kopf nicht verletzt.
Gut.
Haben Sie in Ihrer anderen Verbrechern verletzt?
Verletzung? Nein.
Ich habe eine leichte Schürfe runter.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schürfe?
Ja, ich habe es notiert.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen in Ihrem Schulterbereich auf einer Schmerze,
Kalifornien, 1 bis 10?
Was ist 1? Was ist 10?
Ein, wobei ein ist sehr leichten, sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Okay.
Wenn ich meine Schulter bewege, habe ich Schmerzen um die 8.
Wenn ich die nicht bewege, dann 2.
Können Sie sich mehr genau beschreiben, sind Sie eher brennend oder dumpf?
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht stechend.
Ich kann es nicht beschreiben, halt tot weh.
Schmerz, dumpf oder stechend.
Haben Sie eine Schmerzdatte, Bewegung, Einschränkung oder eine,
wie knichtstärken gehört oder bemerkt?
Ein, was gehört?
Ein Knirchen.
Knirchen?
Ich habe nicht gehört, aber es tut weh.
Ich kann meinen rechten Arm nicht richtig hochheben,
meine rechte Schulter kann ich nicht hochheben, sozusagen.
Ich kann meine Hand oder meine Ellenbogen bewegen,
aber meine Schulter kann ich nicht sehr hochheben.
Ich kann meine Schulter ein bisschen bewegen, aber es eingeschränkt.
Wenn ich mehr als 80 Grad hochhebe, habe ich Schmerzen.
Haben Sie eine Kribbelgefühl oder eine Taupheit in Ihrem Hand oder in Ihrem Arm?
Nein, habe ich mein Gefühl oder ich habe kein Missempfinden,
kein Gefühl oder kein Kribbel in meinem Arm, Hand und Arm, alles komplett.
Okay, strahlen Sie sich mal in eine andere Körperegion?
Ja, der strahlt einmal von meiner Schulter zum Oberarm aus und einmal auch in den vorderen Brustkopfbereich,
bis zu meinem Brustbein ungefähr, kann man sagen.
Von Brustbein bis zur Schulter darfst du zu mir am meisten wehnen.
Okay, Herr Neuberger, fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein?
Haben Sie eine andere Beschwerde?
Nein, andere Beschwerde nicht, aber ich würde sagen,
da, wo meine Schlüsselbein dort ist zwischen Schulter und meinem Brustbein,
gegenüber der linken Seite sieht es ein bisschen verdickter aus.
Sieht so komisch aus, sieht so geschwollen aus.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Linke Seite, Sie haben gesagt.
Rechts.
Linke Seite sieht gut aus.
Rechts Seite.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Fütternfröster danach, Schweiz?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit, der ist gut.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder so genommen?
In der letzten Zeit habe ich nicht.
Ich will ungefähr seit Jahren gleich.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht, ob ich einschlafen kann bei den Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Probleme bei einem Stuhlgerrank oder mit der Wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich kein Problem.
Ist Ihnen übel oder möchten Sie sich erbrechen?
Nein, übel ist es nicht, erbrechen, das Gefühl habe ich auch nicht.
Gibts Ihnen Ihre Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Meine Krankengeschichte.
Was meinen Sie da?
Leiden Sie unter Atelierhypertonie oder Diabetes meleutus
oder Suckerkrankungen oder solche chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich habe nichts von allem.
Ich bin dann kurz gesund, bis auch bei den Schmerzen im Schulterbereich.
Danke.
Könnten Sie noch ein bisschen aussagen?
Ja, wenn ich nicht viel bewege, habe ich kein Problem.
Das geht auch nicht so wenig.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Haben Sie Allergie?
Allergie, ja, Polnallergie.
Früher habe ich Probleme mit Poln.
Wie größert sich die allergische Erkrankung?
Meine Augen jucken und meine Nase löscht ein bisschen.
Ab und zu muss ich mal niesen.
Viele Leute denken, dass ich Corona haben könnte.
Ich habe halt Allergie, kann ich nichts dazu.
Aber sind Sie geimpft?
Ja, ich bin geimpft.
Und geboostet, ja.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Das ist richtig.
Vorher haben Sie geraucht?
Nein, früher habe ich nicht geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich habe nicht geraucht.
Ich habe nicht geraucht, weil ich bei Gelegenheit, wenn ein Party ist.
Ansonsten nicht regelmäßig.
Geburtstagfeier,
irgendeine Party, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht,
aber diese Fragenstellung.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, das ist eine rätinige Frage.
Herr Neuberger,
gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Was meinen Sie da, die Erkrankungen?
Wie Sie vorhin gesagt haben, Bluthochdruck?
Irgendwelche Medikamente wegen Bluthochdruck?
Meine Mutter nimmt Medikamente wegen Zucker ein.
Sie wurde an der Schilddrüse operiert.
Die komplette Schilddrüse wurde genommen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister, ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, er ist gesund.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin ledig.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich bin nur noch Jugendkinder.
Familienplanung.
Hören Sie mal mit 22 Kindern, nicht geplant.
Ja, das ist normal.
Wohnen Sie allein?
Nein, ich wohne bei meinen Eltern.
Herr Neuberger, arbeiten Sie?
Ja, ich studiere.
Ich habe eine Frage vergessen.
Warum war dieser Unfall, Fahrradunfall?
Das war heute ungefähr.
Heute ungefähr vor 2-3 Stunden.
Ich habe meine ganzen Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie mich gefragt?
Ja, ich habe mich gefragt.
Ich habe meine ganzen Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie mich gefragt?
Oder fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein?
Ja, ich wollte noch sagen, Sie haben mir alles gefragt.
Ob ich Drogen einnehme?
Aber wie geht es weiter?
Was wird bei mir gemacht?
Hab ich etwas gebrochen oder habe ich nur etwas gebrannt?
Was ist los?
Ich habe eine Frage, die körperlich untersucht wird.
Ich würde mir ein paar Bildgebende untersuchen.
Wie z.B. die Aufnahme durchführen.
Dann sprechen wir wieder, ob Sie eine Verletzung haben.
Oder eine Verletzung haben.
Ja.
Wie?
Ich habe es nicht gehört.
Die Verletzung war schlecht.
Wir überprüfen mit diesen Untersuchungen.
Ob Sie eine Verletzung haben.
Frakturen, Knochenbrüche oder Bandrissen haben.
Okay.
Kann man mit der Röntgenuntersuchung Bandrissen sehen?
Nein.
Wenn wir diese Verletzungen denken,
wir sollten die Verletzung überprüfen.
Das ist eine Verletzung.
Wir sollten eine MRT anfertigen.
Okay.
Dann los.
Nehmen Sie bitte einen Platz im Wartesma.
Ich würde Sie körperlich überprüfen.
Hallo?
Ja.
Ich habe nicht gehört, aber durchbrühtung
Motoreg sensibilität erfragt.
Hat er gefragt.
Motoreg hat er gefragt, ob ich Bewegungseinstehung habe.
Ich habe schmerzbedingte Bewege-Einstehung gehabt.
Sensibilitätstür, also die Schmerz-Bedingung.
Ich habe die Schmerz-Bedingung.
Ich habe die Schmerz-Beding.
Ich habe den Motoreg Emotionsbett-Beding gefragt.
Sensibilitätstür.
Ich habe den Schmerz-Beding gefragt.
Durchbrühtung hat er nicht gefragt.
Es könnte man fragen.
Ob ein Temperaturunstell,
durch zwischen rechten und linken Arm ist?
Es ist nicht so eine typische Frage.
Man sieht, ob da eine Blauverpärbung ist oder ob kalt oder warm ist der Arm.
Man sieht ja gleich.
Aber für die Prüfung ist es eine Zeitgewinnung, finde ich, kann man fragen.
Man kann ja sagen, haben Sie einen Temperaturunterschied zwischen den beiden Armen bemerkt, im Sinne
von Durchblutungsstörung oder ist es leulich gefärbt der Arm?
Wenn man dann sagt zum Schluss, im Sinne von Durchblutungsstörung, dann weiß derjenige
auch, der fragt irgendwie nicht wegen Entzündung, Dröhtung oder irgendetwas, sondern wegen
Lewideverpärbung oder Temperaturunterschied.
Kann man fragen, muss man glaube ich aber nicht.
Das wäre nicht schlimm.
Aber findet es okay, das kann man sich gut merken.
Die Präferie durch Blutung, Motorik, Sensibilität ist intakt zum Beispiel.
Diese Fragen, wir haben, wir benutzen, wo das nicht zum Beispiel eine Fälle zu gehalten
ist und danach, hier haben wir, hier, wassalasun, Giptes, Blutung, normale Fragen oder?
Ja, beim Fahrradstürz kann man fragen, zum Beispiel warum wegen stumpfem Bauchtrauma zum
Beispiel.
Kann man fragen oder Auffälligkeit beim Urinlasten, ob Blutbeimengung ist, wenn man Urinlasten
würde.
Aber da das vor 3 Stunden, 2-3 Stunden war, der Patient würde sagen, ich habe kein Blut,
weil ich habe ja kein Urin gelassen, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber man kann sagen, wir würden gerne auch noch eine Klipperation zur Suchung machen, wir
würden gerne auch einen Urinprobe nehmen, ob da unbemergte Probleme beim harmableitenden
Legen sein könnte, könnte man sagen.
Man kann fragen, auch wenn man den Kopf nicht stürzt, kann man zum Beispiel Schmerzen im
Bereich der Halswirbelsäule haben, eine Distortion der Halswirbelsäule, könnte auch
sein ohne eine Prellum der Skoppe.
Aber in dem Falle war es nicht.
Aber man kann fragen, ob man, können Sie nochmal genauer erklären, ob Sie ausgerutscht
bestürzt sind oder gegen etwas gefahren sind oder waren Sie bewusstlos und sind Sie
bestürzt.
Er kann ja sein, dass er bewusstlos war und er kann sich nicht erinnern, was da war.
Eine Annesie kann er auch haben.
Zum Beispiel.
Jetzt kann man so nebenbei sagen.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, weil ich habe gefragt, ob die Patienten gegen etwas gestoßen
ist.
Ja genau, aber ich habe ja gesagt, ich bin nicht gestoßen.
Da stimmt.
Aber wenn man noch genauer fragen würde, es kann ja, aber bei 22-Jährigen erwartet man
nicht.
Vielleicht hat er ja ein Diabetes 1 und irgendwie Unterzündung, aber sie haben ja gefragt
um Negenerkrankungen.
Vielleicht ist da eine Erstdiagnose von irgendetwas, Epilepsie oder irgendwas, wo er Fahrrad
gefahren ist und gestürzt ist.
Und der sagt, nee, also ich weiß nicht.
Aber das wäre zu viel, zu genau.
Man kann sowas fragen, aber wenn jemand sagt, ich habe mit dem Kopf keine Verletzung
gehabt und man kann fragen, war es schwarz vor irgendeinem Augen oder Schwindel haben
sie gefragt oder so, schwindelige fühlen, erwächern haben sie gefragt.
Und deswegen kann man sagen, denkt man nicht direkt daran, weil der sagt, ich glaube,
ich habe vorhin erzählt, dass ich mit dem Fahrrad ausgerutscht und gestürzt bin und
auch die liegte Schulter gefallen bin.
Ist das typisch für eine Verletzung im Schulterbereich sozusagen?
Als Patient frage ich nochmal den Herrn Doktor, an was denken Sie denn, Herr Doktor,
das wäre Ihre erste Verdachtsdiagnose.
Soll ich zuerst mein Vorstellung beführen?
Ja, da kann man das auch verstehen.
Ja, da kann man machen, weil das war eine Frage von dem Patient aber egal.
Nachher kommt das Ihnen nochmal.
Wir machen eine Frage.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, wir haben noch einen schönen guten Tag.
Sie sind der neue Astetzer.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja, ich heiße Jagri Bayram.
Ja, ich kann meinen Namen nicht bemerken.
Jagri Bayram?
Jagri Bayram.
Schwerer Name.
Nein.
Jagri, ja, Bayram habe ich auf das gelernt.
Ich möchte heute Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich, deswegen bin ich hier.
Schießen Sie mal los.
Es geht um einen so in 20-Jährigen Patienten, Herrn Jan Neuerberg.
Die Patienten sei 178 cm groß und 80 kg schwer.
Die Patienten stellte sich bei uns in Folge einer Fahrradunfall wegen,
seit 3 Stunden bestehender Stichende Schmerzen im rechten Schulterbereich
mit der Ausstrahlung in den Oberarm und Brustbereich oder Brustkorb.
Okay.
Der Patient bewertete die Intensität der Schmerzen bei der Bewegung 8 von 10
in der Ruhe 2 bis 10.
Die Frage nach Parästhesien und Durchblutung wurde verneint.
Aber der Patient leider unter schmerzhafte Bewegung,
eine Schwellung, außerdem sei mit der Patient eine Idee
am rechten Klöklare Bereich.
Eine Idee würde ich vielleicht nicht sagen.
Ich würde sagen, eher eine Schwellung.
Schwellung würde ich sagen.
Bei Trauma ist meistens eine Schwellung.
Aber ob diese Schwellung eine Idee ist oder was dahinter steckt,
werden wir noch sehen oder hören.
Okay.
Laut den Patienten hat er beim Fahrradfahren mit der rechten Schulter
auf dem Boden hingefahren.
Dann hätten die Schmerzen ausgelöst.
Bei dem Unfall hat der Patient heimgetragen.
Die Vegetative an den Schmerzen,
war unauffällig.
Hat er noch andere Verletzungen?
Die Frage nach anderen Verletzungen
und Kopfverletzungen wurde verneint.
Okay.
Was ist das für eine Frage?
Ja, richtig.
Ich habe vergessen, der Patient habe nach dem Unfall
eine Schnürfung oder Abration an den Knie bemerkt.
Und der Patient hat sich nicht verstanden,
dass er eine Schmerzung hat.
Er hat sich nicht verstanden,
Er hat einen Knie bemerkt.
Am rechten Knie.
Hat der Patient den Tetanerschutz geimpft?
Ja, ich habe diese Frage nicht gefragt.
Ja, kann man noch mal fragen.
Muss man noch ergänzen?
An Vorerkrankungen
bei dem Patient nicht bekannt.
Der Patient nehme keine Regeln,
ob er bedarf, ein Medikament ein.
Der Patient reagiert allergisch auf Polen.
Allergische Reaktionen äußeren sich mit Rinnokonjektivitis.
Herr Neuberger sei nicht Fracher,
trinkte gelegentlich beim Party Alkohol
und Rogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Familien an einem Nest,
fanden sich Arterellehypertonie beim Vater.
Diabetes meines Types war
und Schilddröschung in Vernung.
Oder Tarell-Fachgebegriffe.
Diabetismäletisch-Typ 2
und Schilddröschung in Vernung.
Er ist der Mutter der Patient,
aber ein Bruder, der gesund ist.
Der gesund sei, oder?
Ja, sei.
Herr Neuberger sei Student an der Mechanischen Bau.
An der, ne, Alkohol.
Man ist an der Uni, aber er studiert Maschinenbau.
Er ist Student und studiert Maschinenbau,
kann man zum Beispiel auch sagen.
Aber an der ist ja, wo, an der Uni zum Beispiel.
Er studiert an der Uni.
Er studiert Maschinenbau.
Er sei ledig, lebe mit seinen Eltern.
Und nach der bisherigen Angabe
gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf.
Klavikula-Fraktur, gegebenenfalls
einem Hummus-Corp-Fraktur aus.
Okay, ja, ich würde das trennen.
Ich würde sagen, ich gehe von einer Klavikula-Fraktur aus.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommt man auch an einen
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Okay, also, obang kommt, fragt du.
Und nochmal, wiederholen Sie nochmal bitte.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf.
Klavikula-Fraktur aus.
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen.
Hummus-Corp-Fraktur.
Ja.
Und noch einen, wie?
Klavikula-Fraktur.
Selten, selten.
Der hat ja gesagt, es ist vorne, Torax, vorne des Schmerz.
Ist auch seltener Bruch, kann man ja haben.
Es gibt komplexe Brüche, aber was ist so manchmal,
sehr oft, wenn man im Klavikula-Bereich Schwellungen hat.
Entweder Klavikula-Fraktur oder Tossilesion.
Das heißt, wenn der Klavikula,
Akromioklavikula-Gelenk, da sind Bänder,
wenn die reißen, dann geht die Klavikula
auf oben, so zu meistens immer nach oben.
Akromioklaviklavikulärzung.
Genau, Akromioklaviklavikulärzung oder Tossilesion.
Es gibt verschiedene Küken.
Das ist so die meisten, entweder,
hat der eine Prellung, Oberarmkopf-Fraktur
oder Tossilesion oder ein Tuberkulum-Maius-Fraktur.
Es geht auch, also nicht der Oberarmkopf,
sondern der Tuberkulum, dass der ein Abriss-Fraktur hat.
Das gibt es auch.
Das sind so die meisten Rests.
Das ist ein bisschen zu speziell.
Das reicht.
Wie gesagt, oder eine Prellung.
Da ist eine Schwellung, vielleicht eine Einblutung.
Da ist eine Schwellung, vielleicht nur eine Einblutung,
Hematom, aber es ist nicht vielleicht gebrochen.
Kann auch sein.
Aber wenn da Schwellung ist,
meistens entweder gebrochen oder Tossilesion.
Okay.
Zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich den Patienten
sehr erst vorbeilig untersuchen.
Ich überprüfe auch Zensurik, Motorik und Durchblutung.
Ich taste den Pulsen.
Ich taste auch die Pulse.
Ich taste auch Verletzungbereich,
ob es eine Kriptation gibt.
Ja.
Dann um die Verdacht.
Und das Kniegelenk nicht vergessen.
Was machen Sie am Kniegelenk?
Ich inspitiere auch den Kniegelenk,
ob die Verletzung tief oder nur abschneifende Operation ist.
Ob die verschmutzt ist,
ob die Wunde ein Schmutz hat,
oder ein Femdkörper hat, wie Steine.
Um die Verdachtdiagnose so sichern,
solltet ein Röntgenaufnahme in zwei Ebenen gegebenenfalls Tomografie durchführen?
Ja, aber Röntgenaufnahme in zwei Ebenen.
Was würden Sie für eine Röntgenaufnahme in zwei Ebenen veranlassen?
Wie heißt die Röntgenaufnahme?
Schulterröntgenaufnahme.
Wenn Sie denken, das eine Klaviklarfraktur ist,
dann macht man eher eine Röntgenklaviklar in zwei Ebenen.
Und wenn man Schulterröntgen würde,
würde man die Klaviklarmediale Klaviklar nicht sehen.
Ja, richtig.
Wenn Sie gesagt haben,
meine Verdachtdiagnose ist ober am Kopffraktur,
dann würde man erst mal die Schulteraufnahme machen.
Vielleicht ergänzen später auch die Klaviklarfraktur.
Wenn man denkt, das ist Klaviklarfraktur,
dann würde man erst, weil auch da Schwellung ist,
Klaviklar rechts in zwei Ebenen durchführen lassen.
Und eventuell als Ergänzung auch die Schultergelenk.
Man kann ja auch zwei Palästern haben.
Man weiß ja nicht.
Okay.
Gut.
Und dann haben Sie gesagt,
bei unklaren Befunden kann man auch CT durchführen.
Ja, CT oder MRT, genau.
Kommt drauf an, was man genau wissen möchte.
Okay.
Ja.
Wenn wir eine Fraktur haben,
sollten wir eine, oder unsere Therapie
abhängig von unseren Röntgen befunden.
Wenn wir eine Konservativtherapie planen,
finden wir auch, was heißt das?
Acht, Mandasch.
Mandasch?
Rucksack.
Ja, genau. Richtig.
Das sieht aus wie Surchantasie, Rucksackverband.
Rucksackverband,
oder wenn ein Akromiakularverletzung gibt,
könnte auch Armschlinge durchführen.
Kann man auch, ja.
Ja.
Wenn eine operative Behandlung erforderlich ist,
sollten wir eine Stabilisation durchplaten.
Oder manchmal, wenn ein Akromiakularverletzung gibt,
kann ein Buton- oder Platensynthes durchführen.
Mit Osthösynthese kann man das stabilisieren.
In diesem Fall würde ich den Patient operativ vorbereiten.
Man würde noch ergänzend Laboruntersuche machen für die Narkoseverbreitung.
Ja.
Vorher braucht man nicht bei normaler Verletzung,
wenn da keine Dislocation vorliegt,
aber wenn eine Dislocation vorliegt,
dann müsste man das genauer eventuell untersuchen.
Eventuell speziell untersuchen machen, wenn es sein muss.
Und dann plant man die operative Durchführung.
So kann man.
Man kann eigentlich generell sagen,
man kann immer operativ untersuchen.
Man kann immer operativ und konservativ Empfehlungen geben.
Die Frage ist immer abhängig, was Sie vorhin gesagt haben.
Abhängig von den bildgebenden Verfahren,
wird man sich herantasten.
Ja.
Okay.
Wie Sie es gesagt haben.
Mit eventuell konservativ mit Bandagen und Analgesie.
Oder mit einer Armschlinge oder mit operativen Versorgung.
Es gibt verschiedene Verfahren.
Okay.
Gut.